in House of the Dragon episode 9 the
king is dead and his body is not even
cold before his family starts fighting
for his throne this episode focuses on
Alison's family The Greens in their
plots to make aegon King so what happens
and what does it mean this video has no
spoilers for future episodes except for
some minor background info the opening
sequence family tree has been updated
the symbol for King viserys is now
flooded with blood to show that he's
dead the symbol for Alison Hightower now
shows the Hightower sigil within the
star of the faith of the seven Allison's
daughter Helena has a symbol of a spider
because Helena likes Bugs and she
stitches a spider picture this episode
aegon's symbol looks like a woman and a
dragon egg and aemon's symbol is a
sapphire because in the books aemond
wears a sapphire in his empty the eye
socket the Bloodlines also show that
Alison has a fourth child who we haven't
seen yet a son named Daron the author
George Martin said they couldn't fit
daeron into this season of Hot D but
daeron will appear in season two for now
dayron is in Old Town serving Lord
Hightower as a cup Bearer so his symbol
is a cup aegon now has three children
with Helena a girl named Jahira and a
boy named joharis and a boy named maylor
in the books jahiris has six fingers on
one of his hands and six toes on each
foot soja Harris and jahira's symbols
are six-fingered hands the first person
to discover that king viserys is dead is
this servant boy with his blonde hair he
kind of looks like a Targaryen this
episode reveals that aegon has some
bastard children so we might wonder if
this boy could be a secret Targaryen
bastard or maybe he's just blonde the
boy tells Talia that the king is dead so
Talia tells Queen Alison but then Talia
lights some candles in a window as a
signal to tell mazaria that the king is
dead because Talia is a spy for mazaria
and mazaria can use this information to
her Advantage by kidnapping Prince aegon
Alison believes that viserys wanted
their son aegon to be king and that's
not true Alison misunderstood viserys's
words but she believes that this is her
husband's dying wish we see Alison's
grief for viserys this is deeply
personal for her but at Council Alison
sees that Otto Thailand and Jasper don't
care about viserys's wishes because they
were already plotting to Crown aegon
secretly scheming behind Allison's back
they plan to make the city watch loyal
to them they'll move the Crown's gold
for safe keeping they plan alliances
with the tullys tyrells and baratheons
and they don't include Alison in their
plans Alison had thought that as the
queen they respected her enough to
include her but apparently not Allison
learns that Otto plans to kill rhaenyra
so that rhaenyra can't Challenge aegon
and Allison is outraged for all her
disagreements with Rainier she doesn't
want Rainier murdered she wants to honor
her dead husband's wishes so Alison and
Otto both want aegon to be king but
while Otto is willing to murder Alison
wants a peaceful transition and this is
a change from the books in the books
Alison doesn't protect rhaenyra in fact
she reportedly hopes that rhaenyra will
die in childbirth the show makes Alison
more peaceful and sympathetic the books
also include more specific arguments
over the success session like Otto says
that they can't let rhaenyra be Queen
because she's married to Daemon and
Daemon would be a terrible cruel
murderous King consort Jasper says that
aegon should be king because of the
succession laws that put men before
women and because the harrenhall council
chose the male viserys over the female
rhaenys while Kristen says that rhaenyra
should not rule because she's a [ __ ] who
will make the red keep a big [ __ ]
brothel Kristen is still really butt
hurt about being rejected by rhaenyra
the only one to stand up for rhaenyra is
Lyman beesberry Layman often seemed to
be a weak and irrelevant old man but he
refuses to go along with this coup he
says viserys always said that rhaenyra
was his Heir and they can't just change
the succession based on Alison's word
that he changed his mind on his deathbed
Lyman hints that viserys may have been
murdered in the book mushroom claims
that Allison poisoned viserys Kristen is
angered by the insult to Alison so he
slams Lyman down and Lyman is killed
with a stone Council ball to the head in
the books there are three different
stories of how Lyman dies Eustace says
that Kristen Cut lyman's Throat mushroom
says that Kristen threw Layman out a
window and Orwell says that Lyman was
just imprisoned and then died of a chill
the book Fire and Blood plays with
unreliable narration rumor and bias
twisting the truth or while is one of
the historical sources for this part of
the book and all while sometimes lies to
make himself look good Harold says that
Kristen should be removed from the
kingsguard for murdering Lyman just as
Kristen previously murdered Joffrey
lawnmuth but Alison again protects
Kristen because he's useful to her the
kingsguard are meant to be a sacred
Brotherhood of noble knights not
murderers helping to steal the throne so
Harold is outraged that the kingsguard
are being corrupted by politics
Otto tells Harold to go and arrest
rhaenyra but Harold was Rainier's friend
and protector since she was a kid he
won't give her up to the greens to be
murdered he doesn't accept their
Authority because he's sworn to serve
the king and there is no King so Harold
removes his cloak and leaves kind of
like when Barrister leaves in Game of
Thrones maybe Harold will turn up again
later to support a different ruler like
barristan does the greens are ready to
make aegon the new king but magon is
missing so Alison and Otto race to find
him Alison hopes that if she finds aegon
first she'll be able to influence aegon
to make sure that the succession happens
peacefully without hurting rhaenyra she
could even get aegon to remove Otto it
was hand of the king or to behold aegon
hostage if necessary as brenley says in
Game of Thrones he who holds the king
holds the kingdom in the books Tyrion
and Cersei both try to capture tommen
for themselves sometimes the king is
used as a pawn in the Game of Thrones
Otto sends the twins Sir Eric and Sir
Eric to find aegon while Alison sends
Kristen and amond the teams Race Across
the city searching for Clues to find
aegon it's like The Amazing Race and the
prize is a drunk Prince Alison tells
Helena and amond that their father
viserys is dead Alison tries to comfort
Helena but she pulls away Alison's
children are difficult to love
Otto and Alison want the King's death to
stay secret until they're ready to take
power so they Round Up servants and
Lords at the keep and lock them up so
they can't blab terrain era rainis is
locked in in her room
Otto makes the Lords swear to support
aegon these aren't like all the Lords in
Westeros it's just the minor Lords who
happen to be at the red keep today most
of them agree to support aegon but Lord
Meriwether and Lady Phil refuse house
Meriwether rules long table in the reach
and house fell rules felwood in the
stormlands Merryweather and fell are old
enough that they were probably at the
ceremony years ago when everyone swore
to support rhaenyra so they refused to
break their Oath by supporting aegon and
Otto imprisons these loyalists Lord Alan
Caswell wants to support rhaenyra we've
seen him friendly with rhaenyra before
so Alan pretends to support aegon but
then he tries to escape the red keep to
go and tell rhaenyra that the greens are
stealing her throne but Alan is captured
and Otto and Laris put Alan to death
Alan is hanged in the red keep Courtyard
as a warning to other Rebels Alison asks
rhaenys to support her rhaenys is
effectively in charge of the powerful
house valerion and rhaenys has the Great
Dragon melis so rhaenys could be a
powerful Ally for aegon and the greens
Alison says that siding with rhaenyra
has only hurt rhaenys and her family
Allison says that rhaenys should have
been the queen of Westeros but since
rhaenys and Alison can't rule the realm
themselves they should instead influence
king aegon and the council gently
guiding the kingdom towards peace but
Rainey says that's [ __ ] she and
Alison don't have real power when
they're serving men like rhaenys told
Corliss for years that his Ambitions put
their children in danger but Corliss
didn't listen and now their children are
dead and Corliss is near death Allison
is the queen yet even she doesn't have
power when it matters like when the men
take over the succession and plot murder
and War without her so Rainey says that
gentle female influence within this
patriarchy is just a window in their
prison cell it's an illusion and the
only real power is taking the throne
itself and that's what rhaenyra wants to
do unlike Alison rhaenyra has always
resisted the rules of sex and gender she
wants to be the first woman on the
throne she said that she'll create a new
order rhaenys doesn't much believe in
rhaenyra either she told rhaenyra that
she'll fail to change the system
rhaenys's actor says that after rainis's
own failure to take the throne she
almost wants to believe that the
patriarchy can't be touched that no
woman will truly rule Westeros but
rhaenys is impressed by Alison's
determination and desire for peace she
may be feels hope as well as cynicism
and resentment and feels fear that this
conflict may cause more death Kristen
and amond search for aegon aemond wears
a hood and Kristen wears a hat as though
the cosplaying rhaenyra and Daemon in
episode 4. they go to a brothel that
amond and aegon had visited as teenagers
a woman there recognizes aemond and he
seems embarrassed maybe he lost his
virginity to this woman maybe he feels
ashamed we don't know much about aemon's
sexuality but aegon isn't here so Amon
says that aegon could be captured or
dead or on a ship to Yi T is a powerful
Empire in the Far East inspired by
Imperial China Corliss valerion is one
of the few westerosi who have been to
yeti on his famous voyages HBO is
developing an animated spin-off show
about EET called the Golden Empire amond
is mad that aegon gets to be king when
aegon is an irresponsible [ __ ] while
amond studies hard and trains so he
thinks that he should be king aemond
claims that he is next in line for the
throne which is not true legally aegon's
children are his heirs before his
brother amond though there is a fan
theory that amond might actually be the
father of Helena's children that they
have a secret incestuous love affair
that have been several sibling love
triangles in the books this is a classic
Targaryen move and amond has shown
interest in Helena before while aegon
mostly ignores Helena and if amond was
secretly the father of Helena's children
then amond would legally be aegon's Heir
but that's just a wild Theory the point
is that aemond has that jealous Second
Son syndrome that we've seen in Daemon
and vemond wanting what their older
brother has Helena says this episode
that it's human nature to be envious of
what others have Envy is a big
motivation for many characters in this
story Kristen understands how aemond
feels because Kristen is a lower class
person who's had to work harder for his
status on the kingsguard compared to the
rich privileged sons of Lords Kristen
resents rhaenyra for her privilege he
once called her a spoiled c word which
is funny because in this episode he says
that all women should be respected
Kristen is both chivalrous and
misogynistic he uses his image as a
noble White Knight to hide his hateful
nature aemond says that he and Kristen
are decent men with no taste for
depravity which is nonsense because
Kristen killed a man just this more
morning Kristen once beat a man to death
at a wedding but the rules of honor and
chivalry in this world allow bad people
to call themselves righteous Allison
does the same thing using her cloak of
righteousness to hide her jealousy and
hate amond and Kristen can't find aegon
because they don't know where aegon
hangs out but Eric is aegon's sworn
protector his personal God so Eric knows
that aegon often visits this child
fighting pit here children with sharp
filed teeth fight each other for
entertainment this is the deep dark
underbelly of King's Landing and aegon
participates in this evil aegon has a
bastard child who he leaves here in the
pit not exactly father of the year aegon
is a monster and yet this is the guy who
they're making King Eric says that aegon
is is unfair to rule they shouldn't
support him as king but his twin Eric
wants to keep his oath and stay loyal to
aegon a woman called Jane reveals that
mazaria has aegon so Otto meets with
mazaria mazaria has worked with Otto
before as a spymaster but this is the
first time Otto has met the white worm
in person mazaria says that she has
aegon hostage and she could kill him
she'll release aegon if Otto ends the
use of children in the fighting pits we
know that mazario was once a slave we
see a scar on mazaria's neck we know she
has suffered so mazaria sympathizes with
these exploited children and wants them
freed or perhaps she wants to use these
kids in her child's spy Network seems
kind of hypocritical that she also uses
kids But Otto says they'll look into the
fighting pits and mazaria tells him
where aegon is Missouri area probably
doesn't really trust Otto to actually
close the fighting bits mazaria has been
betrayed and let down before but this is
more about sending a message mazaria
tells Otto that the common people are
powerful and if Otto and King aegon
don't treat the people right there will
be consequences in Game of Thrones we
see the power of the people in riots and
uprisings Eric and Eric find aegon in
the sept it's ironic to find this drunk
depraved [ __ ] in a sacred holy place
but before they can take aegon to Otto
they're stopped by Kristen and amond who
want to take aegon to Alison arik fights
Kristen but his brother Eric just
watches and does nothing Eric doesn't
want to help Crown the Monstrous aegon
and he realizes that he can't change
arik's mind so Eric leaves to support
rhaenyra instead this conflict is
dividing families even putting these
twins on opposite sides aegon tells
amond to let him go so that aegon can
flee the country aegon doesn't want to
be king he says he'd be a terrible King
and amond agrees but aegon is the eldest
son so his family drags him Kicking and
Screaming onto the throne so Allison
captures aegon she wins the game and now
that she holds the prince she controls
the succession she tells Otto that they
won't kill Rainier they'll make rhaenyra
a good peace offer so Rainier and her
family can go into Exile in the East
like Daenerys and viserys did in Game of
Thrones Alison will make Kristen the
commander of the kingsguard to replace
Harold and they will Crown aegon King of
Westeros the scene is shot to mirror a
scene from episode 1. Back Then Otto
totally controlled Alison he pushed her
into marrying viserys and made her the
queen but now Allah elephant finally
sees how much Otto manipulated her for
his own goals after years of obedience
Alison now finally Rebels against her
father and takes charge as her own power
and Otto's reaction is to say that
Alison looks like her mother it's like
in episode 1 when he tells Alison to
wear her mother's dress to comfort
viserys Alison is trying to assert
herself as a political equal here but
Otto makes it about her appearance as a
woman he also says that Alison's
reluctance to kill rhaenyra is
squeamishness as though Alison is too
delicate a lady to do a murder
Otto doesn't understand that Alison's
Mercy is a serious moral and political
decision not a weakness like rhaenyra
with viserys Alison is frustrated that
her father still sees her as his little
girl not as an equal larus finds out the
mazaria has spies in the red keep people
like Talia and that blonde kid and Otto
has been allowing this so that he can
benefit from the spying Alison doesn't
trust mazaria or Otto at this point so
she asks Laris to kill mazaria and Lara
sends one of his fireflies to burn
mazaria's house last time laros burned
people Alison was shocked and horrified
but now she's asking larus to murder
people for her Alison is slowly
embracing Larissa's evil and Laris might
be manipulating Alison earlier he seemed
to offer to spy on Alison for Otto larus
is playing both sides and we still don't
know how larus found out about
rhaenyra's Moon tea maybe larys is
actually working with mazaria and her
spies we don't see if mazaria dies in
that fire maybe laros actually let her
go larus is true motivations are a
mystery but we do know one thing he
likes feet as payment for his Services
Alison shows Laris her bare feet for him
to masturbate to this seems to be an
ongoing thing Laris gives her secrets
and does murders so Allison shows him
her fate since larus has a deformed foot
himself it kind of makes sense that he's
got a foot thing and it's not just about
sex Laris enjoys having power over
people making them uncomfortable like
those prisoners previously maybe after a
lifetime of being disrespected for being
disabled larus enjoys dominating others
and humiliating the queen would be the
ultimate power trip we get a nice
brooding Montage as the characters
contemplate their awful decisions and
Eric comes to free rainies Eric wants to
help rhaenerys side instead of aegon so
Eric and rainey's Escape through one of
the keep's secret passages rhaenys
stares at the skull of balerion a
reminder of the power danger and death
they are risking in this conflict on the
way out rhaenys is caught up in a flood
of people heading for the dragon pit the
greens heard the common folk like sheep
towards the dragon pit for aegon's
coronation Alison takes aegon to his
coronation and aegon says the truth that
viserys obviously didn't want aegon to
be king because viserys didn't like
aegon after aegon stopped being a cute
baby viserys seemed to ignore his son
except to occasionally shout at him so
of course viserys didn't choose aegon to
be king aegon laughs at the absurdity of
the idea though he also feels the pain
of his father's rejection aegon is a lot
like Tyrion in the later books Tyrion
also feels rejected and unloved and also
does horrible things in the books Alison
gives aegon the Valyrian steel knife
that was once aegon the conquerors this
knife symbolizes the huge responsibility
of the throne and represents the
prophecy that the targaryens must be
United to defeat the white walkers aegon
doesn't even know about this prophecy so
he is so not ready for this
responsibility Alison tells aegon that
as king he should not be cruel and he
should not kill rhaenyra but aegon
doesn't listen aegon never listened to
Alison he's never cared about other
people's feelings aegon is a rapist who
leaves his own children in fighting pits
he should not be king but his mother
Alison blindly pushes him into politics
just like Otto pushed Alison into
politics all aegon wants is love he asks
Alison if she loves him and she calls
him an imbecile the dragon pit is a big
open space that's well fortified against
attack so it's where the greens hold
aegon's coronation this is where the
Royal kids had Dragon lessons previously
the Targaryen dragons are kept in
tunnels below so with much Pomp and
pageantry aegon comes to claim his crown
the Grandeur of the ceremony contrasts
with the ugly depravity that brought
aegon here septon Eustis anoints aegon
with a seven holy oils of the faith of
the seven septon Eustis is one of the
main historical sources in Fire and
Blood alongside mushroom and Orwell
aegon wears the crown of aegon the
Conqueror the conqueror's crown is made
of Valyrian steel decorated with rubies
which is different to the crown worn by
viserys and jiharis before him that
Crown is gold decorated with sigils of
the houses of Westeros so it symbolizes
peace and unity while aegon the
conqueror's crown is more warlike aegon
also wears the conqueror's knife and the
conqueror's legendary Valyrian steel
sword blackfyre these are important
symbols of political legitimacy Varys
says that power resides where men
believe it resides and Men believe that
whoever has the king's crown and the
sword and is Anointed by the septon and
has the name aegon Targaryen and blonde
hair and is a firstborn son that man is
the rightful King as far as most people
are concerned when aegon is crowned he
looks to his family he gets a nod from
Allison Helena looks unhappy she doesn't
want to be Queen and amond looks jealous
because he wants the throne but then
aegon looks to the common folk and the
people cheer for him and aegon loves it
because aegon feels so rejected by by
his family he is desperate for affection
so now suddenly when he gets a wave of
love from the people it's the validation
that he's always wanted so now maybe
aegon will decide he wants to be king
after all maybe the love of the people
will change aegon maybe he'll actually
try to be a good King there's a similar
scene in Game of Thrones where Joffrey
discovers the love of the common people
and that didn't make Joffrey suddenly a
good person this moment of Triumph for
the greens is rudely interrupted by a
dragon rhaenys had sneaked down into the
pit to get her dragon mellies and she
decides to escape by bursting up through
the floor of the Dragon pit killing a
lot of innocent people rhaenys faces the
greens and she almost decides to Kill
Them All to end their power grab but
then rhaenys looks into Alison's eyes
sees her protecting her son aegon the
green
cousins does she really want to murder
her extended family after rhaenys has
recently lost her own children and her
husband lies wounded Alison had told
rhaenys that she truly wants Peace So
rhenice gives peace a chance she lets
the greens live and flies off stomping
several more common people in the
process so rhaenys shows Mercy to the
greens but she massacres innocent common
folk like it's nothing many Lords and
Ladies don't care much about the lives
of peasants when the Lords play their
Game of Thrones it's always the innocent
people who suffer especially when
dragons are involved previously we saw
daemon's Dragon stomp on one of his own
soldiers in Game of Thrones daenerys's
dragons eat innocent children viserys
said that dragons are a dangerous
uncontrollable power and often when the
targaryens use their dragons innocent
people people die the targaryens might
not think that matters but mazaria
warned us of the power of the people so
rhaenis's mass murder may have
consequences aegon's coronation fulfills
viserys's prophecy about his son being
King and wearing aegon's crown and
melies bursting up through the floor
fulfills Helena's prophecy about a beast
beneath the boards but there are deeper
meanings to that prophecy like the
beastly aegon is found beneath an altar
intercept and beneath the grand ceremony
of the coronation is the political
Corruption of the greens beneath the
power of the Targaryen dragons are
hidden beasts mazaria and Laris are
symbolized by worms and fireflies
spiders and bees and wasps are also
mentioned this episode with their hidden
passages and deadly Secrets they too are
beasts beneath the boards Daemon said
that everyone is capable of depravity
we've seen the violence beneath
Allison's courtesy beneath Kristen's
chivalry and beneath Otto's cold
Politics as this conflict gets worse
what other beasts will emerge From Below
if you want to know the full story of
Hot D you've got to check out the book
Fire and Blood there's also the main
series of Game of Thrones books and the
world book and dunk and egg you can get
any one of these on audiobook for free
right now at audible.com ASX sign up for
a Premium Plus trial membership and you
can get an audiobook to keep even if you
cancel the trial you can get any Game of
Thrones book or Lord of the Rings or
Dune membership also includes unlimited
access to thousands of audiobooks and
shows in the audible plus catalog sign
up at audible.com ASX or text ASX to
500-500 thank you for watching please
like And subscribe and thank you to the
patrons including Matthias Holm Hansen
Robert Harry Truscott hendo Andrew Lynch
Rohit yalagata and Gabby Joy cheers